mateo gil a averti bonjour merci latran
direct avec nous sur rt france ça fait
maintenant cinq ans que dure cette crise
migratoire au sein de l'union européenne
on voit que c'est très compliqué il ya
quelques jours c'est 180 migrants
étaient bloqués en pleine mer à bord de
l'eau chez andy king ils sont enfin en
sicile neuf jours de blocage et son
situation habituelle pourquoi est-ce si
compliqué d'accoster aujourd'hui déjà je
remarque que les neuf jours passés en
mer sont en période de d'attentes que il
y a un an pratiquement un peu plus d'un
an on avait critiqué quand il y avait un
autre gouvernement et métalliques
étaient accusés parce qu'il y avait
aussi la participation du parti de
mathieu salvini la ligue du nord la
ligue
matteo salvini avait été accusé de
vouloir faire souffrir inutilement des
migrants ce n'était pas digne à l'époque
de faire attendre des migrants sur des
bateaux de toutes façons en sécurité
plus en sécurité par rapport à ce qu'ils
avaient ce qu'ils devaient passer de la
méditerranée et maintenant on voit que
le gouvernement italien qui a le même
président du conseil des ministres donc
je zappais comté fait exactement la même
chose donc la perception maintenant par
contre est beaucoup plus tolérante
vis-à-vis des décisions des roms mais ce
qui montre les décisions des roms c'est
que on ne peut pas
faire arriver tous les migrants
clandestins et surtout on peut pas à
permettre aux associations aux ong de
transporter toutes ces personnes
seulement en italie parce qu'on a vu que
malte a fermé ses portes et les fermes
systématiquement déjà pour un ca tai chi
est minuscule et puis parce qu'elle ne
veut pas d'avoir des complications les
autres pays la grèce a déjà un problème
avec sa frontière terrestre avec la
turquie l'espagne a aussi des frontières
terrestres avec le maroc est donc elle
gère déjà des urgences et les pays du
nord de l'europe ne font pratiquement
rien la france aussi à part à soutenir
vous justement ces ong qui ont des
utilisent des navires qui sont souvent
comment dire des propriétés d'armateurs
de pays de l'europe du nord et qui font
le jeu en tout cas des passeurs qui on
sait d enquête de la magistrature
italienne lot de montres et utilise ce
cette menace des avis des pays européens
pour faire leur commerce et leur trafic
d'êtres humains
alors justement c'est l'europe du sud
qui subit le plus sensé crise migratoire
puisque la plupart des migrants viennent
d'afrique du nord vous l'avez dit les
pays européens qui n'accueille pas assez
voilà deux personnes sur leur territoire
justement horst seehofer demande plus de
solidarité
quels sont les leviers qui voilà qui
peuvent être levés justement par cette
présidence allemande pour pousser à plus
de solidarité envers les migrants
je pense qu'elle est les leviers sont
tout simplement de caractère économique
probablement en tout cas faire peser
tout le poids de l'allemagne sur sur
tous ces pays
ses alliés plus proche donc les pays qui
systématiquement fermé les portes à
l'italie mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que on a un peu l'impression que
le ministre de l'intérieur allemand se
réveille et qui découvre une nouveauté
alors que ça fait cinq ans et plus ce
jeu créé que l'italie et d'autres pays
du sud de l'europe doivent gérer une
crise humanitaire alors que d'autres
pays la france aussi faire
systématiquement leurs frontières
cette crise humanitaire qui est comment
dire
distribuée sur le temps prouve une chose
essentielle que les frontières
européennes existent toujours et que les
états ont tous les droits de les
utiliser
parce que c'est une façon pour éviter
que
comment dire des situations de crise se
forment le problème c'est que étant tous
les pays européens liés par un pacte
solidaire qui borde la d2 la matière des
migrants de la gestion des migrations
on voit que quand on ferme une frontière
ont créé des zones de crise juste au
delà juste sur le territoire du voisin
c'est lâche c'est ce qui se passe avant
timmy entre la france et l'italie
c'est ce qui se passe à calais entre la
france et la grande bretagne qui bientôt
sortir de l'union européenne
définitivement mais bon c'est quelque
chose qui ne peut plus tenir mais que
malheureusement inutile pour surtout les
gouvernements qui soutenus par des
forces de gauche en europe parce que il
affirme ainsi une comment dire à une
nécessité de devoir appliquer le droit
européen sur des situations qui par
contre ne naissent d'une heure d'une
aire d'accueil parce que les trafics
d'êtres humains est un crime
une dernière question très rapidement
matteo jose alberti on sait que la
commission européenne doit présenter en
septembre une proposition de réforme de
la politique migratoire et de l'asile
dont le e s que cela justement peut
aider à régler ce problème de crise
migratoire tout toute mesure est
bienvenue mais j'ai un peu l'impression
que l'allemagne est en tout cas
nous rappelle la commission européenne
et
un produisent des larmes de crocodile
dans l'essence que systématiquement on
voit qu'il y a des problèmes en bois
qu'il ya parfois malheureusement de mort
de nombreux morts dans la mer et
seulement après les pays du nord de
l'europe et leur commission européenne
et réagissent mais de façon très très
très soft à l'eau de rose
merci beaucoup matteo je les ai avertis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de putsch médias